you tweeted an article which I read
earlier on which is really broken down a
lot of the things I wish that I could
understand Brigitte fantasy yeah and
it's called the battle cry of the
politically homeless and what she says
is that people who don't have extremist
views on either sides in their spectrum
or people who just aren't bothered about
politics kind of get lambasted as being
these wasteful of always a cooked serve
ative yeah yeah and a waste of a vote
and then on top of that anyone who is
but is moderate yeah anyone who has a
slightly nuanced view yeah just gets
sort of thrown to the wayside and I
think that with titania what you're
identifying is that the people who are
the absolute extremes yeah that's better
it is funny for that reason that people
can identify most people the vast
majority people yeah can't identify with
them at all yeah exactly that's the I
read the article this morning I think is
a great article amazing she's British
she's an American comic who has had a
lot of flack for just being honest about
her opinions and her opinions as far as
I can see are not particularly
controversial
you know nevertheless yes she's talking
about that idea that there's an
expectation now that you should be
politicized Taylor Swift God would
remember she got so much flak for not
condemning Trump you know and it's like
Taylor Swift silence is deafening so I
don't need to know take a strips of
linen on politics just Taylor Swift for
political advice so in Little Mix
tweeted about the bombing of Syria they
send an apology saying - I was so sorry
to the people of Syria
I bet the people in Syria were thinking
great thank God at least Little Mix have
got our back well I think look I'm not
saying these people we shouldn't have it
with the right to have an opinion of
course they do but I don't give a [ __ ]
what say what little makes think about
Syria yeah that's not their that's not
their expertise is it so anyway yeah so
this is expectation but also what
Bridget's talking about in that article
is the way in which actually because if
you express an honest opinion and then
you get this kind of barrage of hatred
off the back of it it means that people
are becoming nervous about just being
honest so you the discourse is dominated
by the extremes so you have the the woke
left who are really myopic and just
cannot see beyond their own very narrow
house or the parameters
if you step outside a particular you
come from the left like I do and you
step outside it just a little bit you
are the most your the persona non-grata
you're the other one that's straight
down there yeah yeah and and and and so
people who have moderate views people
who just want to have a discussion about
some of these difficult issues they want
to address the nuance of say the trans
debate they will just be lambasted as
bigots was the big irony but this is
these people that know what the word
bigot means I mean the definition of
bigot is someone who is incapable or
completely intolerant of anyone else's
opinion someone who has a different
opinion but they the people so have nine
times attend anyone who calls you a
bigot is normally bitter it's what
they're saying is your opinion shouldn't
be allowed yeah I shouldn't you know we
shouldn't have to it shouldn't be
tolerated so yeah it's a real problem
Bridget's been on the receiving end of a
lot of us have now and of course what
happens as well as if you express an
opinion that isn't within that Overton
Window of acceptable for people just say
when you're being dishonest you're being
a provocateur you're being a shock jock
because it's a kind of narcissistic
worldview that I can't believe that
someone else would have a different view
than me therefore this must be a lie
yeah right so I mean my my my I suppose
my guiding principle is just to tell the
truth say what I think yes and see what
happens
right and I everyone did that can you
imagine with me and if leave me in a
much better position wouldn't ya well do
you know Jordan Peterson who is a fan
favor of the show he his first rule tell
the truth or at least do not lie he
makes the point in his book at about
this actually that is actually very
self-destructive to be dishonest and I'm
when I read that really chimed with me I
think that's absolutely right the you're
hurting yourself if you're if you're
dishonest and he also makes the point
that absolutely there are times when
lying is actually the compassionate
thing to do right fine but actually the
way to do just evading the truth and you
don't have to do lies of omission not
lives of commercial yeah yeah if it's a
poor a compassionate reason that make
that make sense to me but I think when
it comes to just expressing your
opinions and views it's all about
respecting people enough
to tell them the truth as in I can
respect you I can say some that I think
you might disagree with because I
respect you enough as a human being not
to by assume you're not going to start
throwing things and call me a Nazi right
now you're going to have a debate you're
gonna have a discussion yeah it's
actually really disrespectful to say
what you think the popular viewpoint is
just for the sake of other people's
sensibilities that's actually very
disrespectful to them because you're
patronizing them you're infantilizing
them you're saying that you wouldn't be
able to cope with dissent you know it's
a bit like being a screener when your
school like it's particularly thing with
boys at school is that you won't say an
opinion unless you're sure everyone else
at grills right yeah right and sometimes
your this happened to me all the time
you must have to you by when you were a
kid someone said something and
everyone's like oh no we don't think
that do it yeah and then it's like oh no
I didn't mean that
yeah actually sort of stand up doing a
bit about this this year where he's
talking about he when when a situation
arises in the news and he he offers an
opinion a bit too early when it's not
formed and then he said all know can I
take that back
yeah and which is what teenagers do this
isn't a teenage act by the way but it
but that's what teenagers do and it's
that thing of well actually we'd all be
better off being honest if it we know
who we were voting for we'd know what
people think and we know where we stand
we'd have our views challenged there's
all sorts of reasons why honesty is a
good thing but no matter how many times
I say that doesn't matter people just
say yeah you're lying you're just lying
because you want to cause trouble order
and and that's really sad
[Music]
you